[MUSIC PLAYING]
So without further
ado, please help
me give our next president
a warm University
of Arizona welcome.
Dr. Bobby Robbins.
I am very enthusiastic
about getting
started on this important
leadership position.
I wanted to thank the
regents also and the members
of the search committee who
went through a rigorous process.
I was born in a small
town in South Mississippi.
I was raised by my
maternal grandparents.
My grandfather was a
math professor at a small
we call it a junior college.
I went on to a small
liberal arts school
after attending
that junior college
and then to medical school
at University of Mississippi
then to Columbia
University to do research.
Spent two years at NIH.
And then went to Stanford to
do my cardiothoracic surgery
training.
And then from there, the
last 4 and 1/2 years,
I've been the president and
CEO of the Texas Medical
Center, which is the largest
Medical Center in the world.
But I'm appreciative
of the opportunity
and thank you for asking me to
share my own personal story.
This is a great
American university,
and it's something that
we should all be proud of.
The incredible
legacy and history
of the university
around research,
being a research-intensive
university,
I think it's outstanding.
And one of my
objectives as I take
this leadership role is to
tell the great story that I
think we have here at U of A.
The world is changing.
It's changing in ways
that we need to be
and I think are
well-positioned to be
leaders in the area of
diversity, of access,
of affordability.
There is a fast-moving
world out there.
I think that it is tailor-made
for the University of Arizona
to be on the leading
edge of this emerging
industrial revolution.
For the students,
when they go out
in this competitive
global marketplace,
they will be prepared, not only
for the content and the skills
that they get here, but also
to remain intellectually
curious lifelong learners
and to have service
back to the community.
Dr. Robbins, welcome.
I am thrilled to
have you on board.
Yours is a story
that we really need
to get out to the
public on what you
are doing with less
resources and trying
to make a difference for
the state of Arizona.
So thank you very much.
Thank you for those
kind comments.
I move that the board appoint
Dr. Robert Robbins as president
of the University of
Arizona and approve
his multiple-year
employment contract
and that the board
authorized me as board chair
to sign the contract
with Dr. Robbins.
Is there a second?
Second.
Discussion.
You've heard the motion.
Those in favor simply
count by saying aye.
Aye.
Those opposed, no.
The ayes do have it.
The ayes do have
it, and so ordered.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]